good morning John I love the Olympics I
love its internationality I love its
history I love a chance to celebrate
with friends and I like watching humans
do extraordinary things but I also have
my problems with the Olympics for
example they seem to have absolutely no
idea how people currently consume media
like we can talk about them banning gifs
we can talk about their social media
opening ceremony with Ryan Seacrest or
we can talk about how it's impossible to
watch the Olympics on the internet
without a cable subscription which most
young people rightly recognize as a
really bad investment but I think if the
Olympic Games can correctly imagine how
media works right now there's a bigger
opportunity that's being missed the
olympics needs to understand itself and
share itself is a massively parallel
viewing experience with lots I mean tons
of different things happening all at the
same time and with distribution and
production costs dropping like a rock I
think that's super totally possible all
they need is a ton of new interesting
and weird events so here are 17 sports
that I think absolutely a hundred
percent should be added to the Olympic
Games number one support Achra
mind-bending game native to Southeast
Asia that's basically volleyball except
played without ham every spike volley
serve and block is done with the head
torso and legs and this game is like 90
percent bicycle kicks it's so cool and I
want it to be celebrated number two tug
of war now I know this might seem a
little bit silly but in fact it used to
be an Olympic sport a mere 100 years ago
it's a fun team sport with simplest dirt
rules that I frankly would love watching
every four years number three wushu you
can think of this as like gymnastics but
also fight wushu is complex and
beautiful and difficult to understand
fully but very easy to enjoy with both
combat versions and an exhibition
version number four cricket I don't know
anything about cricket except that it's
the second most popular game in the
entire world and it's done in the
Olympics and that's done number five
super dope secret handshakes number six
I don't really think that BattleBots is
exactly the thing that I want to see but
the ability to build and operate robots
that destroy other robots it's something
that I would like to see people able to
get a gold medal in yeah number seven
acapella singing which I'm probably just
mentioning because Peter Hollens just
released a collab video that I did with
him
singing hobbit drinking songs and it's
really great and I'm really proud of n
there's a link in the description number
8 kite fighting using kite strings
coated in finely ground glass this South
Asian sport Pitts kite flyers against
each other with the goal of cutting the
other persons kites through sport is
popular from Afghanistan to Vietnam to
Brazil number 9 ultra run the longest
race in the Olympics right now is the
marathon at just over 26 miles
ultra runners regularly race over a
hundred miles sometimes with huge
elevation gains it's one of the most
remarkable things that humans do number
10 cheer now a lot of people belittle -
you're leading but it's pretty amazing
these days I love the idea of cheer
teams cheering for entire nations rather
than just schools or sports teams for 11
Kabaddi it's kind of full-contact tag
each team takes turns having an attacker
raid the other side and they have to get
in there and touch another person on the
other side and then get back across
their line without getting tackled
number 12
parkour obviously number 13 darts
because it's actually really amazing and
it takes no new infrastructure number 14
headus it's like table tennis but with
soccer balls in your head it's so great
number 15
League of Legends because if the
Olympics doesn't get into eSports right
now they're gonna lose an entire
generation finally number 16 mounted
archery because if you've got this and
you've got this then you might as well
have this yeah there are some things
about the Olympics that are necessarily
old-fashioned the pageantry and the
patriotism and I don't think it should
leave those things behind but I do think
that this wonderful and ancient
tradition could do a lot to be more
inclusive of the marvelous cultural
diversity of our species and thanks to
modern technology I think it can be also
they should let us post gifs on tumblr
and twitter because come on John I'll
see you on Tuesday
that's a bilbo baggins taste